welcome to book TV my name is Rohit
Chopra and today I'll be talking to
professor Lisa serve on a professor of
City and regional planning at the
University of Pennsylvania and author of
the un-- banking of America how the new
middle class survives which was just
released this month Lisa thank you for
being here thanks for having me it's
great to be here so let's just start why
did you write this book and who is it
actually written for it's a great
question I wrote the book in a nutshell
because I could not understand
originally why if alternative financial
services like check cashers and payday
lenders were so bad for people why so
many people were using them and in the
course of my research which took a few
years I learned that banks were not
really serving the low below and
increasingly the middle class and I also
realized that there were some good
alternatives coming on board and so I
kind of wanted to tell that whole story
it's the first book I've written that's
not an academic book meaning it's really
accessible for a wider audience and so I
wrote it for policy makers for people
who are working in the financial
services industry and also for people
like you and me who may or may not be
happy with the consumer financial
services that they're currently using
great so let's talk a little bit about
what you mean by alternative financial
services providers select level-set yeah
on what's that and what why do you call
it alternative yeah that's a good
question
so I see the consumer financial services
industry as being broken into three
components one would I'd call a
mainstream component which is banks and
credit unions for the most part the
second is alternative check cashers
payday lenders pawnshops rent-to-own
shops there's a whole set of them and
they're growing as consumer financial
services changes and technology grows
and then the third is informal financial
services which are not really on the map
of policymakers so much but they're used
by many many Americans and so you talked
a little bit about how people think some
of these alternative
providers are quote unquote bad yeah and
say more about why why you think that
that's the impression and it may be true
but put a finer point yeah sure so you
know when I started doing this work I
was reading about consumer financial
services and the way that many policy
makers had framed the issue
the FDIC primarily the Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation which has put out
every two years now for several years
something called the survey of banked
and unbanked households and they were
kind of looking they had kind of created
this framework of banks unbanked and
underbanked banked being households that
use a bank account and do not use
alternative financial services unbanked
being those people who have no bank
account at all and under banks being
people who have a bank account but also
rely on alternative financial services
and the message the message of those
policy reports really was that everyone
should use a bank account the latest
research says that about 20% of
Americans are under banked another 8%
are unbanked have no bank account at all
and the implicit message was banks are
definitely best for people and those who
traffic in on the alternative financial
services are predatory they're sleazy
they're part of the poverty industry
they're just out to take advantage of
people and you know that's when I got
back to this original question or what
led me to the question that made me say
you know what if so many people are
using these services there must be a
reason besides the fact that they're
ignorant or don't know any better
because I've done work in low-income
communities for 20 years for my whole
career and I know that families who have
very little money know where every penny
goes and so it struck me that there had
to be a better reason for why people
were using these services now in your
book you're slightly critical of
mainstream banks essentially you talk
about how they're more interested in
earning revenue through fees as opposed
to interest that their business model
has changed
in fact now you tell a great story about
the community bank that you First Bank
that right yeah and it's interesting
because I wasn't really thinking about
that when I started this research but
ultimately I ended up working as a
teller at a check casher and at a payday
lender and it kind of took me back to my
childhood story which was I grew up in a
small immigrant town in central New
Jersey my grandparents came from Poland
in the 30s and I grew up there and I
went to the bank with my dad on Saturday
mornings we would go to the butcher we'd
go to the post office my dad would get
his haircut and we'd end up at the bank
so it was like these other spaces it was
sort of a community space you'd bump
into neighbors my dad knew all of the
tellers and the tellers knew him and I
would you know get a lollipop or
something and like it like other kids
and when I was about 7 I got my first
bank account and for viewers who are my
age or a little bit older it was a green
passbook with gold letters and I got I
put my birthday money there I put
savings from my allowance if I didn't
spend it
I put the tips that I earned as a
waitress later on and it felt like a
rite of passage you know and I only
realized later that I had been
conditioned to be a particular kind of
financial services consumer as a result
of that Earl early interaction with the
bank and now obviously my relationship
with a bank like most people is
different when my kids think of going to
the bank they think of this machine on
the side of a building that spits out
dollar bills and I don't know any
tellers that my bank and they don't know
me but I think what we've lost sight of
is the fact that it's not only that kind
of relationship piece of the equation
that's changed as you mentioned the way
the banks make money has changed as well
so dad back in that era the late 60s
early 70s when I was going to the bank
with my dad banks were making most of
their money from interest you would make
3.3 percent interest on your savings
account you'd get you'd pay 6% for a
loan and it was called the 363 era of
banking bankers would be able to go to
the golf course by 3:00 and finish up
their day
so that doesn't happen anymore and
what's changed is that interest rates
became a less predictable way for them
to make money regulators said look you
know interest rates are volatile we saw
what happened with the savings and loan
crisis so you need another way to figure
out how to make money and that's when
banks discovered fees the same fees that
angered most of the people that I talked
to we now pay between 27 and 35 dollars
if you overdraft on your account banks
made more than 32 billion dollars last
year in overdraft fees alone and so that
business model and there are lots of
other fees that I could talk about has
created a situation where those of us
who have more money to keep in an
account can afford the monthly fees or
not pay them because we can afford the
minimum balance we tend not to overdraft
our accounts very often because we have
enough of a buffer and we don't make
those kinds of miscalculations that
people who live closer to the edge do
and it's driven a lot of people away
from banks so what does your research
show about how does lower income people
Bank a generation ago were they being
served by these community banks or were
they always outside of the system well
that's interesting I mean technically
many of them were being served however
we have an act called the Community
Reinvestment Act that was passed in 1977
and that Act was really a response to
banks redlining in other words drawing
red lines around particular
neighborhoods where they refused to lend
so in that sense banks were not serving
everyone well and it was largely
low-income people people of color
immigrants in communities who felt like
the banks weren't serving them the act
was a response to that it didn't really
have any teeth until 1992 when President
Clinton amended it so while banks were
not using fees as much as an income
generator there was still discrimination
in the markets and there continues to be
even though there are laws in place we
see African Americans paying more for
credit being denied prime mortgages or
getting subprime more
much more often women being charged two
percent more on credit cards yeah and we
saw that so clearly in the mortgage
crisis yes where so many people of color
who would have qualified for a prime
mortgage actually didn't get one and
some of the results of that was very it
was very difficult to modify those
mortgages so how much do you think those
troubles changed the public's trust
in banking I think I think it changed
the trust and banking a lot across the
board so banks people the sort of trust
in banking overall is at an all-time low
as you mentioned african-american and
Latinos lost much more of their wealth
the wealth that they had before the
crisis and they were starting from a
lower base so that the crisis was
devastating and it often it can be
traced back to differential differential
mortgages being offered right so so
Trust is is at an all-time low I think
the people who are at least able to
bounce back from that have been the most
hurt and have the least amount of trust
and so in your book ah
you talk about how when you worked in
some of these alternative financial
services providers that you actually saw
that trust link which you were not
expecting I think yeah so you know the
reason I went to work as a teller in
both of these places was that it seemed
like the only way I could answer this
question of why so many people were
using these services and so I spent four
months in the South Bronx working at a
checks check casher as a teller and then
three weeks full-time working as a
lender and as a loan collector at a
payday lender in Oakland California and
what I saw was well I noticed that many
people talked about having bank accounts
as well but doing certain things at one
place or another and then after both of
those stints as tellers I came out from
behind the counter and I interviewed a
lot of the customers and sort of
told them why I had been doing the work
there and wanted to talk together
upfront with everyone I was upfront yeah
I wasn't fine it wasn't wouldn't been
completely ethical to pretend like I was
just working as a teller and I stuck out
like a sore arm also but when I talked
to people about why they weren't using
banks or why they had closed their bank
accounts
I found that about 50% of the check
casher people check casher customers I
interviewed either had bank accounts or
had had them in the past and closed them
and the three things that they talked
about in terms of why they chose to use
the check casher were that it was less
expensive which was completely
counterintuitive to everything I'd read
that the check casher was more
transparent that they felt like they
knew what they would be paying and when
they would be paying it there were no
surprises and that they trusted it more
that they felt like they had
relationships with the people who worked
there and that they didn't get very good
service at the banks it's very
interesting because so many people look
at check cashing almost with some moral
condemnation yeah when I was a regulator
at the Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau we would hear you know you have
to do something about check cashers but
you know when I would play devil's
advocate I would say the check-cashing
is perhaps one of the most transparent
financial products there is out there
and you talk about how at the store you
were at it was very clearly marked what
the prices were for specific services
yeah I mean when I speak to audiences of
people I like to ask whether people have
ever been into a check casher or a
payday lender and if you haven't I would
recommend you go walk in one because
they're all over the place and if you
walk in the signage that spans the
teller windows looks like McDonald's to
me that's what I think of it's got all
the products listed what's for sale how
much you pay for each so for example
when I worked at the check casher it
costs one point nine five percent of the
face value of the check to cash it it
cost a dollar fifty to send a bill
people like to get their bills paid
their to cost eighty nine cents for a
money order up to five hundred dollars
which is less than what the post office
charges and so people would often come
and do their banking there they would
come say on
Friday when I got their check and they
would bring their bills and you know
they would cash the check I'd give them
their cash and then they would kind of
portion out the money on top of the
bills oftentimes not paying the full
bill because they couldn't afford it but
maybe figuring out how much do I have to
pay to the phone company or to to the
electric company to get heat from
getting my lights turned off and maybe
paying their rent in full because they
knew that they had to do that and then
whatever they had left was the money
they had to live on for the until their
next paycheck but I think they also they
were happy in the knowledge that they
they knew what they were getting how
much it cost and they knew those bills
would be paid immediately right so if
they had deposited that same check into
their bank account and then written
checks or gone online to pay their bills
it would have been hard for them to be
certain that those bills would be would
hit their account was after the check
cleared one of the biggest complaints
from people was that they put their
check in their account and they didn't
know exactly when it would clear and
sometimes they needed to pay the bills
right away or face a late fee they
needed to buy food for their families
over the weekend so it it was an
expensive decision but it was also a
logical one so in the book you talk
about a situation where a customer is
unable to make the $20 payment right and
how you saw a surprising response from
the from the establishment right right
yeah that's the story I told about a
woman named Martha who is a Puerto Rican
women in her 50s and she came in
regularly to cash a government check
that she got I don't remember if it was
once a month or once every two weeks but
she came to my window and I scanned her
checked
put her customer ID number and saw her
information come up on my computer
screen and what I saw was a message that
said she had to pay us $20 every time
she came in which I had never seen
before so I asked one of the other
tellers to explain to me what I needed
to do and she said oh yeah Martha cashed
a bad check last month or her check
didn't clear for some reason and so we
just created an arrangement with her
that she'll pay it
back $20 every every time she comes in
which was interesting in and of itself
right because if you've gone to a bank
probably that you would have been you
would have been charged a bad check see
and that that transaction would have
been logged in check systems which is
the system that all banks use to keep
track of their customers kind of bad
behavior and if you have too much of
that bad behavior even if it's not your
fault you may be you may be kicked out
of your bank account and because the
bank share it you will be able to get
another account for several years I just
heard a story about this over the
weekend anyway so Martha says I can't
pay the $20 today because I've had an
emergency medical expense so again what
do we do do we say sorry we need the $20
do we cash or check the teller who was
working with me said no of course we're
going to check casher check she's a good
customer and she'll just pay us next
time so that's a good example the reason
I told that story in the book was it's
an evidence of how the relationship
still matters at many of these
businesses whereas it's very hard at a
bank to get that kind of service and to
figure out have them help resolve your
problems without having you being
penalized in this in the process so do
you see this as banks essentially not
serving this population well and
creating opportunity for alternative
providers or do you see it as
alternative providers are just out
foxing the banks I think you know
there's been such a change and I think
banks frankly they make more money off
of those of us who have more money so
the guy who hired me at write check in
the South Bronx Joe Coleman said by way
of illustration he said look Lisa banks
want one customer with a million dollars
and check cashers want a million
customers with one dollar so that speaks
to the basic business model right and no
one can argue with that banks like every
other profit seeking corporation want to
maximize their profit the question is
whether they're being ethical in the
process or not and whether banks because
they have a critical role in the economy
that the
little bit different from other service
providers or say manufacturers should be
held to a different set of rules I do
think that it is creating an opportunity
for the alternatives and also for other
businesses that are springing up now
that are looking to kind of solve the
problem in another way so you see people
in this industry called FinTech
financial technology who are creating
different products and services that are
to some extent designed to fill this gap
in the market that's been left that
caused people to choose either banks
that they can't afford or somewhat
expensive alternative financial services
providers so so we'll get back to
FinTech I want to ask you about you in
some might argue that you offer a little
bit of a sympathetic portrayal of some
an alternative financial services
provider space but you also caution that
they also need to be regulated and to
curb some of the abuse so how do you
feel about that balance it's a very
tough balance and it's particularly
tough because there are now five federal
agencies that regulate financial
services providers and not all of those
regulators you know that's better than I
do talk to each other get along with
each other they're not all necessarily
coordinated and that's not even counting
two states that's right and and it's
important to point out that all of these
check cashers and payday lenders are
regulated at the state level not the
federal level except for the CFPB which
you mentioned which is coming down with
some regulations on payday lenders which
is probably a good place to a good
example of how to talk about regulation
so right now we have a situation where
12 or 13 states are are not it's not
legal to make payday loans so the states
have come down about that the the other
states that do provide them have
different fees different interest rates
different terms it's very hard to make
sense of it from a consumer perspective
and you have people crossing state lines
or getting loans from online lenders in
order to get those loans in this is a
case where I think the federal federal
regulation is really appropriate where
it makes sense to have a uniform set of
laws and where I think
some of the some of the rules that are
coming down from the CFPB make a lot of
sense probably the most specific one is
the ability to pay regulation so what
people have argued consumer advocates
and some policy makers is that people
who take out payday loans are not using
them the way they were designed and
maybe for people who live in a state
where these things aren't legal it's
instructive to just say briefly what
they are payday loans are very small
loans usually between 50 and 300 dollars
that have very quick due dates they're
due in full either two weeks or four
weeks after they're issued depending on
the next pay day or the next check data
of the borrower and they're expensive
and that they cost where I work 15
dollars per hundred borrowed the reason
that they're not used as advertised is
that many people find that if they take
that hundred dollar loan and it's due in
two weeks they can't pay it back in two
weeks the situation that caused them to
take it out in the first place has maybe
been rectified maybe not but they
haven't gotten a windfall to compensate
for it so they end up taking out that
loan again for another two weeks and
paying another $15 so it's true that
that's problematic you get somebody then
playing $30.00 for essentially the same
hundred dollar loan Moodle keeps giving
the gesture and fast exactly so they can
be paying much more than they borrowed
ultimately so what the CFPB is is
prepared to do is to say you need to
lender ascertain whether the borrower is
going to be able to pay that back now
that's hard to do but I want to kind of
set that aside for the moment and say
that that makes some sense and the fact
that the lenders will have to do some
work to underwrite that loan before the
customer can get it the borrower can get
it creates space for other other
competitors into the market
what borrowers want most is to get that
loan immediately and they do now they
come to the store they within 10 minutes
they've got the dollars in their hand
and they usually need it for an
emergency but if there's a short waiting
period that will allow other lenders who
are making loans much more
cheaply one I like in California is
called opportune which makes loans at
about 36% some people still think that's
too expensive but it definitely lowers
the cost for a lot of people from from a
payday loan which is three hundred to
six hundred percent APR so how do you
see this space needing to be regulated
so you you are looking at the CFPB
rulemaking what do you think states are
doing right or not right you mentioned
some of them outright bantam yeah you
specifically mention the experience of
Colorado yes where do you see the states
being particularly smart or not smart on
this issue well from an academic
perspective or a research perspective
it's really interesting because you have
all of these different experiments that
are going on all over the place
what Colorado did was was outlaw these
what lump sum loans the loan where you
have to pay the whole thing back
immediately and they made them turn into
installment loans meaning you take out
that hundred dollars and you have a
longer time period to pay it back I
think overall that's probably a good
thing because it gives people more time
it probably lessens the cost and the
likelihood that they'll have to roll it
over so that's one interesting thing I
think we need to do more research on
some of these before and after kinds of
things in some instances it appears that
when a state has outlawed payday loans
outright that there's been an increase
in usage of overdraft and an overdraft
which is essentially a short-term loan
also has something like a 5,000 percent
APR if you kind of converted the
interest rate and made it
apples-to-apples with a payday loan so
we have to be careful that we don't just
think we're doing something better and
make sure that the outcomes are actually
better and I think we need to do more
research to figure that out but I think
the trends overall and many of the
lenders are now starting to change in
anticipation of the payday loans of the
rules coming down from the CFPB to
installment loans and I think that is
that is going to help but there's
probably going to be a frankly a stall
right now in terms of the state
regulation while people are waiting for
those
those rules to come down now we're
seeing in the financial markets that
some financial institutions and
investors are looking closer and
increasing their investments in subprime
credit card lending yes so how do you
think more subprime credit card lending
which has changed quite a bit since the
card act right will that be a big threat
to payday lending I think it has the
potential to be I write about one of
these cards in my books a build card
that was that was created by sanwei
summer and the build card was really
created as to to be more transparent
more ethical alternative to payday loans
the idea was to target people who would
have otherwise taken out payday loans I
think it has a 500 dollar limit so that
certainly limits someone's opportunity
to get a large loan but it does offer
the ability to pay it back in
installments and for people to have a
little bit of leeway to know that they
have that credit instead of having to go
out and apply for it when the emergency
hits and to manage it so the studies
have build so far it hasn't been out for
very long look pretty promising and I
think given the kinds of work that went
on with the card Act to curtail bad
practices I think there is quite a
potential for for some credit cards
marketed to the subprime population to
make a difference and to be a real
alternative to this group so some people
would argue that a complete ban on
payday style lending or even a used to
recap you mentioned in the book you
reference the military Lending Act which
caps the APR for loans to servicemembers
some would argue that those types of
interventions actually create the
environment for new competitors to come
in to offer better products like such as
when fuel vehicle standards are out
there better cars come onto the market
how do you react to to that type of
argument well I think as I mentioned
before I think if we have these ability
to pay rules for example some
of these some of these regulations will
create a more competitive marketplace
and I do think we see some actors who
are entering in it's it's not it's not
that easy to figure out how to do the
underwriting in order to make a profit
and serve this market right so we've
seen that in fact opportunity endure
about eight years before it made a
profit so they've needed a lot of
venture capital to make their market
work but I think some of the some of the
models like that could scale up and
certainly if there are these kinds of
regulations that lower the cap lower the
usery cap or or outright ban them that
we may see innovation come up from the
bottom I think you know one of the
central questions here is is expensive
credit better than no credit at all and
the thing that I worry about and one of
the things that I really try to do in
the book is to not just have that
argument about whether we should ban
payday lenders or not but to look at the
situations that people find themselves
in and to understand it from their
perspective and to because I think you
know there's what the focus that being
almost solely on lenders we we run the
risk of saying like well let's just ban
them all out right and then we still
have the demand right so to separate
kind of the supply issue from the demand
issue look at them both but also focus
on the conditions that have made payday
lending swell to such levels and frankly
to start to become used regularly by
people who look like they should be in
the middle class and not have to have
these solutions so I think you know we
need to have those questions of what to
do about it but we also need to be
looking at what happens to people who
are in these situations where they're
making choices that I can't imagine
making you know whether I should take
out this loan or have my kids go hungry
for the weekend whether I should fix my
car taking out an expensive loan or lose
my job because I can't get to work and
you know we hear those stories but I'm
not sure if people really think about
what it would be like to walk in the
shoes as people who
making those choices yeah I agree and
though the evidence is a little bit
mixed as the extent to which people are
using it for emergencies or whether
they're simply on the treadmill ensuite
that's right before that's right and
same with credit cards too we see an
increasing usage of credit cards for
basic expenses for food for utilities
etc so our that may be because of
incentives that credit card companies
give us but we also see a shift in use
over time in terms of when people think
it's appropriate to take on credit so
let's talk a little bit about the
regulator's yeah so by your comments it
sounds that you really feel that the
FDIC has really put a moral preference
on having a bank account or that they
are favored essentially the idea that
every citizen should have a bank account
do you think every citizen should have a
bank account I don't think it makes
sense for every citizen right now I
think you know it works for me it works
for people like me who have stable
incomes and good jobs and can afford to
save and can afford to have a high
regular relatively high balance but I
think the banking industry needs to
change
in order for that to be the suitable
answer for every American and I think we
have it a little bit backwards you know
some of the programs that are being
pushed are for people to open bank
accounts but without making sure that
the products and services that are
available for them actually work for
them credit unions are often a viable
alternative sometimes community banks
but not always and it's also not that
easy for people to figure out how and
when to it does make sense to open a
bank account and where to do that so
lots of people I talked to say they're
not happy with their bank but they don't
know what to do and what the
alternatives are yeah well you talked
about the data about how more and more
financial institutions are really
dependent on overdraft fee's yeah and
other charges like this and and it's not
just your big banks it's true of smaller
banks as well isn't it that's right and
so you
I am concerned about the fact that the
four largest banks hold half of our
deposits and that the number of smaller
banks has diminished radically over the
last two decades at the same time I
think a lot of smaller banks have felt
like they need to adopt some of the same
practices in order to compete and that's
troubling and it also makes it harder
for people to say well I'll just go to
the bank on my corner because that will
be better it's not it's not too
formulaic anymore I do have a button on
my website lissa serve on.com it's
called how to leave your bank which does
provide consumers with some information
about how they can go about figuring out
whether the financial services that
they're using now are the best for them
and for example where they can find a
credit union that they could join so
what else do you think the regulator's
need to change about their mindset you
mentioned a little bit that there may be
partial to banks over non-bank financial
providers but but what else so I think
there are things that regulators could
do to solve some of the problems that my
customers told me about when I worked in
the check casher and the payday lender
one I talked about was transparency
right so you know I kind of painted that
picture of what it looks like when you
walk into a check casher most people who
are watching probably know what it looks
like when they walk into their bank
branch but they may not have registered
that you don't see anywhere what's for
sale what are the products how much do
they cost what are their different kind
of options versus Visa these are the
overdraft fee's and actually the law now
says that you have to opt in to
overdraft protection but most people
I've surveyed don't know whether they
opted in or out so lifting up these
important decisions about what kind of
account you're going to get whether it
makes sense for you to have overdraft
protection or not those are really
important one of the things that I
advocate for my book is something like a
financial facts box that would accompany
every financial product or service the
way that we have Nutrition Facts boxes
on our decide of breakfast cereal and
bread and pasta sauce that shows exactly
what is in that so you could actually
stand side by side
we not in the bank because we don't have
a kind of financial services marketplace
you know we would be nice but online
where you could at least say I'm going
to compare this checking account to that
one nerd wallet is a site that I like
that helps people do that so that's one
thing another thing that I think the
regulator's could help us do is to
evaluate one provider over another a
little bit better and you know you and I
both live in New York City we live in a
city where restaurants are regulated by
the Health Department and every
restaurant has an a B or C in its window
a big blue letter it's hard to miss and
I don't know about you but I do not
order Thai food from the bees and the
Seas and minun line into my neighborhood
because I don't know I don't want to
know about what's going on in their
kitchens but we could do the same thing
the CFPB is the perfect agency because
it does have jurisdiction over payday
lenders check cashers and banks so that
people could say like okay this is kind
of a Housekeeping Good Housekeeping Seal
of Approval finally one third thing I
have lots of ideas but I'll just talk
about one here is that there are
products and services that very
innovative people are trying to create
to help serve people better in the
consumer financial services industry
that are having trouble getting through
the regulation that you need to get
through to get that product to market so
you know the FDA has the ability to have
provoked drug drug makers test drugs
before they go on the market to see if
they're safe the UK has a financial
services regulatory sandbox that would
allow financial services creators to do
the same thing to kind of test market
something before it has to go through
all of those regulatory hurdles so those
are three things I think that regulators
could do to help speed up solving this
problem yeah so the CFPB as you know
does have a project catalyst that is
helping innovators bring new products to
market how do you think the regulators
need to change in terms of interacting
with new providers that may be offering
more competition to a market that often
sorely lacks it
well I think kind of opening up the
regulations and being a little bit more
open to it is the first thing and to
realize to have conversations with these
providers and work with them more
closely to make a determination about
whether those products are safe versus
harmful before just kind of seeing that
they don't fit into the pre-existing box
I think regulators are often out of
habit of the mindset of kind of viewing
products that are coming that
pre-existing institutions like banks and
now we have a lot of entrepreneurs who
are coming from all different sectors
that are creating products and systems
not always products that have the
potential to help people but because
they don't fit into one of those
pre-existing boxes they kind of don't
make it through the screen it's
interesting my experience as a regulator
is every time regulators try to work
with entrepreneurs and innovators the
banks are the ones who really get upset
about it because those are the
technologies that really could disrupt
their business models that's right well
that's interesting that you say that you
know some of the people that I spoke
with who are the innovators when I said
you know why aren't the banks doing this
instead of you guys partly what they
said was that these are little they're
almost like little laboratories that are
funded with relatively small amounts of
money they're very nimble sometimes the
people who had them up have had
experience in the banking industry and
in the policy agnus policy makers and
you know what they say is the banks
don't really they're not as dynamic and
nimble and able to talk across silos as
these newer FinTech organizations are
and that you know they kind of rather
have these experiments going on at the
micro level and then the banks will just
buy them if they you know say since
there's a future for them so that's a
possibility too that banks will innovate
not by growing these things organically
but by purchasing other firms that's
right
yeah now tell me a you spend some time
in the book talking about Millennials
and the millennial experience with
banking ones that they will not be going
into a branch but they certainly
have maybe day-to-day contact with
payment apps or other banking services
how do you see that changing the
business of banking yeah good question I
mean first of all Millennials I think
get a bad rap when it comes to money
they actually are saving at higher rates
than the previous generation did and
they're pretty on top of it
significantly higher free nificantly
higher rates yes so we think of them as
being this kind of irresponsible
generation that's simply relying on
their parents to fund what they do but
they're actually being pretty savvy they
have a lot of student debt for example
and so they have no choice but to really
think about how they're going to deal
with that they are the largest
generation even larger than baby boomers
25% of our population so no matter what
we say about them they will change the
face of consumer financial services and
the four biggest banks make they're all
make their top ten list of least liked
kind of most hated brands so they are
not big into the kind of old
brick-and-mortar they didn't grow up
like I did go into the bank with my dad
so there's no kind of loyalty or
patterning that happened with them if
anything they experienced banks like my
kids do as being ATMs and saw their
parents doing things online and they're
much more comfortable than people
Generation X or wires at using their
phones to transmit information you know
people like my mom who's 80 has a kind
of an instinctive risk aversion when she
thinks about putting any of her
information into a phone or even a
computer right but this generation
doesn't think that way and they're very
willing to use apps like venmo which
allows them to pay each other back
really easily if they've shared a cab
ride or a meal they're very willing to
look at banks that don't have
bricks-and-mortar offices so doing all
of their banking in a mobile way and
they tend to do the research to make to
make their choices and also listen to
their peers so people my age tend to go
online look at things and compare and
Millennials will talk to each other and
that's have some of these apps and other
things spread like wildfire so I think
there's a real there
a real opportunity for for bankers and
for other financial services providers
to figure out how what makes that group
tick and to develop applications and
products for them and they've shown that
they're really willing to experiment and
one of the things people forget is that
so many people who are Millennials came
of age during a financial crash right
they saw their mother father lose their
job they may have seen their family go
through foreclosure and we see it in the
data since the collapse of Lehman
Brothers student debt has more than
doubled and more Millennials are working
yeah sometimes through college so how do
you think we change the view that the
public has of Millennials who are just
leeching off their parents in the
basement yeah I don't know I mean right
about it I think right about how they
are doing things that are that are
responsible in terms of their money and
I think the other thing that we have to
do is with all of the stuff that we've
been talking about over the last however
many minutes is to think about how the
condition of the American worker has
really changed and Millennials are
really coming maybe the first generation
to really face a very different reality
and one of the things that really struck
me when I did focus groups and
interviews with people that age was how
they did not relate to the American
Dream as it was kind of put in front of
me and my parents of you know being able
to get a good job that came with a
stable predictable income job one job
per person maybe even one job per
household although that's not the way it
wasn't my house buy a home save for
retirement save your kids college mean
my parents were both teachers not very
fancy jobs but they were stable and they
allowed them to do all of those things
I've talked to lots of people who have
master's degrees and said you know if I
take the job of my dreams I might not be
able to have children or I definitely
won't be able to MIT to buy a house and
so we're still kind of projecting that
American dream as though it's a reality
but they're kind of waking up as they
graduate from college or graduate school
and saying I don't think I can I don't
think that's a reality and that
sometimes they feel like they've fallen
short we have this huge problem I think
of shame and embarrassment and personal
failing around money and sometimes
they're resentful or just resigned by
saying you know my parents had this but
it's not going to be for me so I don't
know if that really changes the larger
public's perception but I think they've
gotten kind of a raw deal and we look at
only maybe the fact that they're moving
back home or not gainfully employed and
judge them for that without looking at
this larger context which frankly is the
same context that has created an upsurge
in use of payday loans and check cashers
and in some kind of some sense is it
living at home maybe the more
financially responsible thing to do for
men you that's right I mean I'm glad I
did not have to go back home so I don't
think we should just assume that yeah
these young people are so happy to go
back and move in with mom and dad and
have their laundry done and their meals
cook for them you know if they're also
feeling like they can't grow up and kind
of go through these stages of adulthood
and it's because of this financial
context and do you think it will make
Millennials more skeptical of taking on
debt especially after their student debt
experience I think it will I mean you
know I definitely talked to some people
for whom their debt was already so big
that they felt like you know what's a
little bit more but I would say on the
whole many of them are feeling like yeah
they're very reticent to run up their
credit cards or to you know take on debt
to buy a house or something because
they're not so sure that they can rely
on that income you know one of the most
disturbing aspects of my interviews with
Millennials was how many people talked
about not being able to do things like
go to their friends weddings or go home
for holidays which seemed like luxuries
maybe but I thought about it in terms of
their social networks you know that
these as we we as Americans don't always
live close to where we grow up and you
depend on these kinds of life events
in order to maintain that that web of
support and they often had to opt out of
those things because they just in order
to be financially responsible they
couldn't participate but then they felt
that those ties were weakening and I
think from the perspective of civil
society that that's a troubling thing
yeah I heard from one gentleman who had
a student loan who and he defaulted and
his grandmother was a cosigner and his
relatives did not really want him to
come home for Thanksgiving because his
grandmother was being financially harmed
by it so I think it does impact people's
psyche as well when they default yeah I
think it absolutely does and I also
talked to many parents who did not
expect to have to take in their adult
children and were squeezed by those
obligations and kind of felt like the
parents were taking out loans that they
shouldn't have taken on because they
wanted to help their children and and
first you know felt guilty as parents do
even when things aren't their fault so
there are really strong
intergenerational dynamics happening
here but the upside of more Millennials
in the financial services marketplace is
that there may be more opportunities for
innovation and disruption absolutely so
you spend a good amount of time talking
about some of the companies you've
already mentioned but what do you see do
you see these thin tech providers or
innovators do you think any of them
really has a chance to fundamentally
transform the business of banking in the
open marketplace I think I think they do
and I would say I would just amend your
question a little bit to say financial
services not just banking right so I'll
talk about two that I think are not
about products and services but that can
change kind of the infrastructure of
banking and credit one of them I'm one
of them I write about in the book is
called ripple which is located in San
Francisco where a lot of the FinTech
happens ripple is a company of startup
that is looking to create what they call
an internet of value kind of like the
Internet of information that we all use
to send
texts around all the time it would
create a system that would enable money
to move from one place to another
without cost and immediately the same
way it happens if I send you an email
right so what that does if that catches
on and it looks like it's got a pretty
good chance of doing it is it makes it
possible for me to deposit that check in
my account and have it available to me
immediately
now I don't have to wait the three or
four days for it to clear in my account
or if I want to remit money to my
relatives in Guatemala or send money
across the country those things are
rather expensive if you go to a Western
Union or a check casher so that right
there eliminates a huge barrier to
people getting bank accounts right
because they can get their money when
they need it so that's one innovation
that has you know it has to do almost
with the plumbing of the banking system
but not the products and services itself
another one is around credit scoring I
looked at a firm called L to see that
was recently bought by trans Union which
is one of the three big credit bureaus
and what they've done is pilot a new
credit scoring formula so you know if I
were to get my credit score done right
now it would kind of look at a snapshot
of me today how much money I'm using at
the credit I have available and whether
I've been late on things and what my
bank says about whether it overdrafted
or not this other new credit scoring
model looks at a thirty day period so
it's a broader period of time not just a
snapshot which is like liable to be more
fair and it also looks at all kinds of
other assets and liabilities that are
kind of on my personal balance sheet
including did I pay my rent and my
utilities things that your typical
credit score doesn't have does not
include exactly and what mike monde le
the founder of LTC found is that first
off there are millions of people in the
United States who have no credit score
which means if they try to get a loan
they're going to pay a lot of money for
it that
because they don't have the information
that traditional credit bureaus use well
if you apply this different credit
scoring model they can all be scored and
many of them get prime scores if you
rescore everyone the millions of
who are considered subprime many of them
moved to prime and super prime so if
that credit scoring model was instituted
on a much larger scale we'd see millions
and millions of people who would have
access to cheaper better credit right so
those two things those innovations are
kind of like these systems that run
underneath the whole system but that
would really open up the financial
markets and existing financial services
to a much wider group of people but
there's certainly some losers from those
innovations
there's certainly industries that depend
on slower deposits clearing in people's
bank accounts there's certainly as you
mentioned companies that make quite a
bit of money sending money overseas will
those companies die or will they simply
figure out a way to stop those
innovations from moving forward it's
hard to say you know I don't know the
ins and outs of Western Union as well as
probably I should but I think it's
likely that companies would want to take
on the innovation and compete right what
happens now for example is that you know
if I go to Western Union or a check
casher to send money to Guatemala all I
really see is my money going across the
counter and a pretty hefty fee but the
money will stop several times between
here and my cousin in Guatemala let's
just say and every time it stops it
takes a little time and it costs a
little money and there's a potential for
error
and that the folks who work in this
industry call that friction so what the
ripple folks are doing is trying to take
that friction out of the system we found
the surface that would be good for
Western Union to it because it will be
able to compete with other providers how
about this evening exactly there may be
some winnowing in those industries but
that's creative destruction you know
that's that's how industry always works
and I think in this case the benefits to
the consumer make it reasonable to
follow those innovations so let's talk
about some of the other solutions that
you think are important
other than fostering innovation you
actually embrace some of the
pushes do we increase the Postal
Service's participation in the financial
services marketplace and tell us more
about that sure well I think it's a
start off I would say that we've had
we've had a range of relationships when
we think of the relationship between the
banking sector and the public sector if
we go back to Supreme Court justice
Louis Brandeis and Thomas Jefferson and
Woodrow Wilson they all argued that the
banking system was kind of like the
railroads you know it was sort of a
public utility it was a different
structure a different kind of it was a
part of the infrastructure mate that
makes the economy run and so that and
banks get particular kinds of benefits
from government like the FDIC's
insurance which you know after the crash
of 29 we instituted this insurance that
created a system so that if you put your
money in a bank you wouldn't lose it if
the banks went bust so that's a big
advantage to the banks and so the
argument is that banks should do
something in return for that insurance
and other kinds of benefits they get
favorable treatment on loans from the
government etc what's happened really
since the 80s when we entered a big long
period of deregulation is that that
relationship has kind of moved from
banks being responsible to a larger
public interest to banks being more
responsible to their own profitability
and efficiency and government enabling
that so that's all context to say that I
think we need to move that relationship
back more to decide where banks have to
do more in the public interest and I
think there are a few ways to do that
the postal banking service system that's
been proposed off and on by many people
is one way to do that in which post
offices the postal system would create
bank accounts for people and provide
financial services and that was done for
a period mostly for immigrants earlier
in the century got kind of phased out
but the argument is that the postal
service would not be in the business of
making a huge profit from it but rather
providing these services as part of what
it does now the last time that
was raised as as an idea was four or
five years ago and it was a white paper
coming from the inspector general's
office of the Postal Service and that
paper argued that it would be a benefit
to consumers and also that the Postal
Service could make a profit which I
don't think is really feasible nor
should be the desired goal I think we
should consider a public banking system
through the Postal Service or not but
that the reason to do it would be simply
be that it's the right thing to do that
that it should be a right of every
citizen to have safe affordable access
to financial services other things that
I think we could do along those lines
one is that we have a program right now
called the Lifeline program that gives
all Americans access to telephone
service the argument and I believe it
was created under Reagan was that you
know you need a phone line in order to
call for one one or 911 call phone to
participate in the job market and so if
you can't afford a phone will subsidize
the phone service providers to make it
available to you well we could do that
same logic to think about banks - given
the amount of money that's being made
it's hard to argue that they should be
subsidized to do this but but it's also
doesn't fit their business model they're
not necessarily making a profit on these
people so that's something I think that
could be considered as well so I
definitely think we need to pursue more
of these ideas that get government more
involved in financial services although
in the current administration I don't
think that's a likely prospect so what's
the likelihood do you think of advancing
what you call in the book financial
justice what do you think is the roadmap
for that in these very uncertain times
yeah well I think the first thing that
we need to do is to really think about
what financial justice means are all
Americans being treated the same way by
financial institutions and in other ways
that are a little bit maybe outside of
the the actual financial services system
but very much linked up with it and
those kinds of things I would liken to
what happened in Ferguson where we saw
Ferguson Missouri where we saw African
Americans important
neighborhoods being unfairly targeted
for things like broken taillights and
minor infractions that led them to
basically fund the municipal system debt
collection practices that target certain
groups over others so I think the first
step and this is something I'm starting
to work on myself is to kind of collect
all of that information and lift it up
to show that as we sit right now that
the fact that there is a huge amount of
financial injustice in terms of certain
groups and individuals being targeted in
different ways and paying more and then
I think the next thing is to really kind
of change the way that we're talking
about this issue right now as I
mentioned before we we still use these
categories of unbanked banked and
underbanked which I think also have a
kind of deficiency built into them you
know it sounds like you're unhealthy or
you're uneducated or there's something
wrong with you exactly if we change the
conversation to be one that focuses on
financial health which is something the
Center for financial services innovation
has really pioneered then we get to a
different conversation we start asking
what do what do Americans need in order
to be able to budget and plan to save
for retirement to deal with the shock to
their income these things that have
become increasingly common but that
Americans are less and less able to deal
with and I think that's the beginning of
the roadmap to then start to argue for
policies that enable financial health
you know defining the problem is one of
unbanked
given the way that banks are working
with lower and moderate income people
and this new middle class it doesn't
make sense as a solution so we have to
redefine the problem well professor
serve and I just want to thank you for
being here today the book again is the
unbanked
it's available in bookstores and online
and we hope you all take a look at it
thanks so much thank you